[Musik]
chris ich bin oberster stelle an der
johannes bin eingesetzt bei dem viel
abonnieren als stellvertretender zugs
kommandant des wasser bewegen pionier
zuges und ich sage ich jetzt dass sturm
boot welches 2014 beim österreichischen
bundesheer eingesetzt wurden ist wir
besitzen vielleicht vier stück von
diesem bootstypen das boot selbst hat
eine länge von neun meter 15 eine breite
von 2 meter vierzig ein gewicht von
2400 kilogramm höchst zulässig sind 1500
kilo oder zehn mann
beladung und ich sage ich jetzt den
steuerstand
jetzt am steuerstand ich beginne über
links wenn man doch schaut doch mal die
drehzahlmesser für den motor du noch mal
du eine seerose dort in der mitte das
große mit den riesengrossen bildschirm
ist die re marine sprich unser gps und
radar system muss man bot mitführen
unrecht sommer den internen funk auf der
anderen seite weiter rechts haben haben
wir noch den donau von kress es möglich
ist dass wir es nach gaza straße auch
intern und auch mit allen schiffen
kommunizieren können und die jetzt sage
ich noch das schmuckstück von bot den
motor es ist ein steyr motor der über
290 ps sondern bringt da wo es motiv
multiview list und auf der backbord und
steuerbord zeiten haben wir noch jeweils
ein dank der wo es jeweils 100 liter
diesel forst und im heckbereich ganz
hinten sieht man auch noch den rolls
royce chat
so jetzt einmal noch beim letzten teil
das ist der chat von außen vorteile des
chips wir haben nur eine geringe
wassertiefe wo man überall fahren können
und wir bewegen uns mittels wasserstrahl
voran das heißt die verletzungsgefahr
sehr gering und jetzt sage ich noch die
ausbildung der viele pioniere auf der au
[Musik]